some kids and of course their dads
completing the legendary panini World
Cup sticker album is more important than
the tournament itself with 640 stickers
to collect for this year's edition alone
it's an unforgiving task for both
customer and company we have produced
something like if thin billion stickers
on the World Cup c-470 it's a hell of an
headache for four years because we start
working on the next world cup the day
the winners lift the cup try not to feel
too much sympathy completing this
collector's item could leave you in a
sticky situation according to
mathematicians at the University of
Geneva an avid fan would need to buy 899
packs to complete the album setting you
back over six hundred dollars panini
sales have been rising steadily over the
last decade in World Cup years sales
have surged so all the signs of that
2014 should be a bumper year one of the
reasons for continued sales could be the
elusive player the legendary rare
sticker that plagues the perfect
collection and drives buyers round the
bend however panini insist it's all down
to chance our strategy is to print no
rare stickers at all in a sticker album
we do produce equal quantities and as a
consequence of these if you find on some
market a sticker which people regard as
rare well that is what in Italian we
would say legenda metropolitana it's not
true try telling that to the kids in the
playground tom gibson bling
you